have you ever entered an area in Mist
Gary's Mod gone home controller even the
original doom and had this strange
feeling of deja vu a feeling that the
space you occupy is somehow familiar to
you even though you've never physically
been there before
it's because these games or parts of
them at least take place in liminal
spaces
these games aren't scary and sometimes
aren't even meant to be but they can
conjure up fear more effectively through
their environments than games that are
made to scare us let's talk about the
terror of liminal spaces in video games
wait a minute
how did I get here
what are liminal spaces they're known as
the transitional spaces between two
locations or states of being they are
all around us hallways Alleyways waiting
rooms they are places that are ordinary
and everyday places we normally don't
think about but may in fact be
thresholds between our world
and another but how are liminal space is
used in games you'd be surprised to
learn that you've probably inhabited a
lot of liminal spaces in the games
you've played without even knowing about
it the foggy streets of Silent Hill the
solitary hallways of Doom the
chernobyl-esque Landscapes of Gary's mod
the abandoned streets of Half-Life 2
City 17. actually control comes to mind
as a perfect example of how liminal
spaces are worked into the narrative and
environments of a game the ever-changing
offices brutalist architecture and
foreboding sense that something is
inherently off about the rooms you enter
they even work the mechanics of the
oldest house being a threshold between
Dimensions into the main Narrative of
the game although liminal spaces have
existed in games before we even had a
classification for them liminal spaces
as an aesthetic are a very recent
phenomenon as recent as 2019 to be more
specific the first known instance of a
liminal space photo came from an
anonymous 4chan user on the x-paranormal
board on May 12 2019. the post read post
disquieting images that just feel off
the board was filled with images like
this
and while I don't know the origins of
the first two images I know that the
third exists it's the Holiday Inn at
London Heathrow Airport
and yes the fourth is from wee bowling
nice one
when I look at places like this I get
this strange feeling of deja vu not
necessarily that I've been to the
specific location but I know what it's
like to be in a place like it most
people have been to an office mall or
Courtyard these locations are widespread
I'm working in an office as I type this
script
foreign
I've been fascinated by these Eerie
Landscapes ever since I learned about
them you know as our world has moved
more online with places like malls and
even doctors offices transitioning from
the physical to the virtual these places
that I knew intimately as a kid are
Vanishing and becoming these vague
memories that I have brief Recollections
of and while my memories of these places
aren't scary the disconnect I feel
between the large bustling spaces I
remember and the vast empty Landscapes I
see in liminal space photos deeply
unsettling and I wanted to see how that
fear translates through liminal spaces
in video games so I played four games
that use liminal spaces as their
backdrop escape the back rooms dream
logic and nemoopolis and super liminal
all of these use the core tenets of what
I think makes liminal spaces terrifying
Nostalgia and lifelessness
liminal spaces capture a very particular
form of nostalgia and it's interesting
because this aesthetic is relatively new
but made by people on the internet who
are very aware of how showing something
familiar yet obsolete can stir that
Nostalgia and unease all at the same
time I mean these spaces all look like
they can be from anywhere in the 90s to
the early 2000s and they give me the
same feeling I get when I look at this
[Music]
this is so familiar it's something I
watched as a baby like a Proto cocoa
melon
but I weirdly feel attacked by it in a
similar way the smooth and oddly shaped
Plastics of a cramped indoor play Space
the warm flat lighting of an empty
office and the maniacal design of a
daycare carpet all highlight the sense
of nostalgia that creates a loneliness
when seen in the cold starkness of an
Internet jpeg all four games that I
played use these spaces to great effect
pools after dark The Lazy River with the
fake waterfalls that seems to go on
forever hotel hallways and parking lots
that I'm sure have been to but now only
exist as vague feelings somewhere in the
back of my mind these spaces should be
alive but seem devoid of any human
occupancy it's like someone had to build
them
but without any intention that people
have or Were Meant to exist in them at
all this leads to the second unsettling
fact about liminal spaces
there
[Music]
what makes these spaces so unnerving is
that they should be bustling with
activity offices should be filled with
people working and chatting malls should
be packed with Shoppers moving to and
fro but you were alone in these spaces
utterly
alone appearing on the dock with water
quietly lapping against it and Mist
entering an empty home with all your
childhood belongings in gone home
although there's nothing chasing you no
creature popping up out of event to
slice you up foreign
just as scary as what is
because there should be people around
right this is where the terror comes in
and when talking about Terror with its
relationship to liminal spaces I want to
talk specifically about
the definition of the sublime in its
purest form is the confused ah at the
greatness and darkness that our mind
can't grasp liminal spaces work so well
as a vehicle for Terror because they
allow your imagination to fill in the
blanks of a space you're not currently
in it's like the difference between
being in an earthquake and reading about
one
the horror and panic of experiencing an
earthquake leave nothing to the
imagination it's all happening to you in
real time reading about an earthquake
leaves you terrified and imagining what
the experience could have been like even
if you've been in one before
games are the perfect vehicle for this
because they can put the player in the
shoes of someone going through a
terrifying experience while the player
themselves stays safe on the other side
of a screen
speaking of which let's talk about those
games I was mentioning before I want to
start with escape the back rooms because
there's an important distinction to be
made between which games use liminal
spaces or a sub-genre of them called the
back rooms the main distinction between
the two is that liminal spaces don't
have any context the back rooms add a
narrative to the experience of looking
at a liminal space photo with different
creatures called entities and levels of
the back rooms using different liminal
spaces as their backdrops so in that
case escape the back rooms is
exceptionally true to its name it starts
with your character exploring a 3D
environment based off of the iconic
original back rooms image facing off
against the entities of each level of
the back rooms but this is pure
Creepypasta fodder and not much else fun
to play with friends and a good horror
game experience overall there's nothing
stalking creeping or chasing you in a
liminal space and that's the scariest
part of it your imagination is your
greatest enemy I'm gonna lump a
nimoyopolis and dreamlogic together
because for ninety percent of the game
they encapsulate perfectly the terror of
liminal spaces and then use horror
tropes at the end and don't worry about
pronouncing a demoiopolis the main
character can't do it either animeapolis
and nemalayapolis
animoapolis
I think that's it after falling through
the Earth's surface you're submerged in
an underground pool and very soon you'll
be asking yourself
why are there so many pools in these
games or water-filled hallways at the
very least a lot of it stems from these
types of images
but it also makes sense considering the
corner of our brains that liminal space
is occupied community pools are places
we might have spent a lot of time at as
kids for swimming lessons or maybe fun
at water parks these spaces are also
meant to have tons of people in them
splashing and shouting joyful cries of
kids going down the water slides and
whatnot removing any human interaction
in these spaces is uncanny to say the
least and he goes back to that
disconnect between how you know
something should look and sound and
seeing it as it is an emoapolis does
this exceptionally well from abandoned
water slides to the dingy locker rooms
and back rooms of the underground water
park you found yourself in
and I was terrified the game was so
effective at capitalizing on the terror
of the dimly lit hallways and Eerie
locations that are so enticing about
liminal spaces
until you get to this room
the game hints and so quickly that I had
to double take that you were not alone
in this underground Labyrinth alone in
my apartment I audibly shouted oh God
damn it the reveal was extremely well
done and as a horror game I'm not mad
that they introduced a being to chase
you but what was disappointing was it
feels like the creators of these
experiences don't trust that the
environments alone are terrifying enough
to make me scared although the catharsis
of a jump scare can be fully earned and
welcome the experience of being in a
space that chills you to the Bone can
stay with you way longer than any scary
horror monster will
and dreamlogic is another game that
presents the same dilemma dream logic
takes you from pools to empty highways
parking garages to tight hallways and
eventually the back rooms themselves
until the xylophone section dreamlogic
does a fantastic job of presenting
environment after environment that makes
your imagination go off the rails I
mentioned the xylophone room because at
that point at about 90 through the game
the monster is finally revealed
the game turns from a liminal space game
to a literal backrooms game
but there is a game that captures the
essence and Terror of liminal spaces
without having to compromise
channel is not a horror game it's
actually a puzzle game mortakin to mist
or portal where you use your perspective
and the environments to solve puzzles
until you get to chapter four now I want
to go into full spoiler warning because
this is going to spoil this section of
the game if you want to play it I highly
recommend it so go do that if you want
to skip to this point in the video okay
are we good all right here we go up to
this point in the game the hotel
hallways and hollywood-like backlots
have been uncanny maybe even slightly
unsettling at best but they are brightly
lit with great use of what I like to
call the Wily coyote effect presenting
something visual as genuine and honest
which then turns out to be fake but with
no indication that anything bad or scary
is happening but in chapter 4 they start
by shutting all the lights off the
immediate change in tone is like a
terrifying slap to the face the hallways
feel all the more claustrophobic the
effective use of sight gags like a stack
of signs that say die which then turns
out to be a bunch of boxes of diet soda
using the light of an exit sign to find
your way through the back rooms of a
kitchen mountains of boxes piled up that
you have to squeeze your way through
doors shut behind you Trails of Blood on
the floor and bloody handprints on the
walls this sequence perfectly captures
the terror of liminal spaces because it
allows you to create your own greatest
fears and you may be wondering what
monster was about to pop out of the
Shadows what Creature From Another
Dimension was stalking you
but the truth is
there wasn't one those doors swung
behind you as you pass through because
that's what they do the blood was just
red paint to paint the walls of the
restaurant that the kitchen serve and
the diet soda was just diet soda I loved
this reveal because it didn't feel like
a cop-out a cheap scare or take the game
into backrooms territory instead it only
added to the terror of the liminal
spaces going forward because my
imagination was consistently spinning as
to whether I was safe or even alone in
the spaces I occupied it turned to the
ordinary extraordinary or at least my
mind did
my thoughts about super liminal and
Terror in general are echoed by the king
of horror himself Stephen King I
recognize Terror as the finest emotion
so I will try to terrorize the reader
but if I find I cannot terrify I will
try to horrify and if I find I cannot
horrify I'll go for the gross out I'm
not proud terror is the most powerful
emotion that the horror genre has
because it allows people to dig deep
into their psyches and generate scares
from places that are solely unique to
them for me that fear has a lot to do
with growing up that the places I knew
as a kid are slipping away and changing
in ways that I could have never imagined
and change is good for our growth as
humans don't get me wrong but it can be
unnerving and frankly terrifying
sometimes video games have been a part
of my life since I can remember and for
me a lot of these games exist in the
same way that liminal spaces do Doom
Gary's Mod missed these were some of my
first gaming experiences and when I
think about these deeply nostalgic
virtual spaces I think about the friends
that I used to inhabit them with so now
looking at these spaces feels very empty
and it's not like the games are gone
they're still you know retrospectives uh
low-res screenshots maybe even the Forum
thread
but these are all still very vague
thoughts and
distant feelings
kind of like my memories of those
friendships from so long ago
I get the same feeling looking at these
virtual spaces is I do looking at a
picture of an empty Mall
just boot up the construct map on Gary's
mod and you'll see exactly what I mean
my friend should be there
but they're not